شرقي اسيا حيث بؤره توتر اخرى تشغل الراي
العام العالمي فبعد تجارب كوريا الشماليه
متكرره التي تثير المخاوف والغضب دخل على
ما يبدو عنصرنا اخر في معادله سياسات حافه
الهاويه التي يجري انتهاجها في المنطقه
عن وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه اصدها فجرا
اليوم مسيره صينيه قرب اثنتين من جذورها
الجنوبيه
وحلقت قادمه من بحر شرقي الصين دون ان
تخترق المجال الجويه الياباني وفقا بيان
وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه
لعقيدتها الدفاعيه في مواجهه الصين
ذلك على رئيس الكوري الجنوبي سوكيون انا
بلاده تناقشه مع الولايات المتحده اجراء
مناورات نوويه مشتركه في مواجهه التهديدات
المتناميه لكوريا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
المظله النوويه الامريكيه وردعها الموزع
لم يعد كافيا يطمئنه الكوريين الجنوبيه
مملوكه للولايات المتحده لكن تحضيرها
وتشارك المعلومات والمناورات والتدريبات
يجب ان تجرى بشكل مشترك بين كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده مضيفانا
والشنطن لا تمانعوا تلك الفكره
هذا وقد كان زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم يونج
اون تعهد بتعزيز قوه بلاده العسكريه
وزياده انتاجها من الرؤوس النوويه
والصواريخ بما يمكنها من تنفيذ ضربات
النوويه
موقف الزعيم الكوريه الشماليه دقن وقيس
الخطر في الجاره الجنوبيه اذا سارع وزير
الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي
الى عقد اجتماع طارئ لكبار قاده الجيش
الجنوبيه
ضد اي استفزاز مباشر من الشمال معتبرا ان
تطويرها للاسلحه النوويه يهدف الى تدمير
السلام وان اي استخدام لتلك الاسلحه سيؤدي
الى نهايه نظامكم
لهجتي زعيم الشطر الشمالي دفع المسؤولين
في الجنوب الى اتخاذ مزيدا من التدابير
يعتزم انشاء قسم جديد
من الاسلحه النوويه واسلحه الدمار الشامل
الاخرى من كوريا الشماليه
الجنوبيه
تنظ
مه مشتركه الكوريه الجنوبيه مراسمه
بمناسبه انشاء مديريه مكافحه الاسلحه
النوويه واسلحه دمار الشامل والتي قالت
انها ستضع الاساس للاطلاق المتصور للقياده
الاستراتيجيه
الجزيره مهامت سموره ومن بيجين مديره مكتب
الجزيره ناصر عبد الحق
مها اذا وزاره الدفاع تقول انها رصدت
مسيره صينيه
قرب اثنتين من جذورها الجنوبيه
جنوب اليابان بين ساعات الصباح والظهيره
من نفس اليوم مع العلم بان هذه المسيره لم
تخترق المجال الجوي اليابان الى ان وزاره
الدفاع قد قامت
بدراسه مسارها
باستمرار قوات الدفاع الذاتي الجويه حيث
قامت باتلاقيه طائرات مقاتله من نوع اف 15
همم
تستعد للرد لنفس الوقت بالنسبه للمسيره هي
قد تم الاعلان عنها من خلال سبعه ايام
الكشف عنها في معرض لطائرات الجويه في
مارس من العام المصري حسب وزاره الدفاع هي
تعملوا بالتحقيق على ارتفاعات عاليه
لمتابعه ال همم الحدود ومراقبه همم المياه
ال الاقليميه او
الدوريات ااا
البحريه بالنسبه
للمسيره لا زالت وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه
تتدخل حذر من تحركات الجيش الصيني الذي قد
يجرب او يقوم همم تحريك المزيد من
الطائرات التي تحلق بدون طيار
بهدف تحسين اداءها او تجريبها يتزامنوا
اطلاقه هذه المسير مع انضمام الياباني
لمجلس الامن الدولي يوم امس كعدو من غير
دائم حيث تحتل اليابان ايضا الرئاسه دوريه
الشهريه
يناير كانون الثاني مع العلم بان هذا
المجلس المكون من 15 عضوا لم يستطيع حتى
الان وقفه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا او
حتى كوريا الشماليه من اطلاق صواريخ
البالستيه المتكرره مع ممارسه كل من
العدوين الدائمين روسيا حق النقد ناصر عبد
الحق اا ما تقوله وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه
بخصوص تحليق مسيره صينيه فوق جزيرتيها
الجنوبيهتين كيف ترد عليه بالجين وكيف
تعلق عليه
لم يرد رد من الجانب الصيني او رد رسمي من
الجانب الصيني على همم اعلان وزاره الدفاع
اليابانيه لكن نعلم ان الصين قامت بعده
همم مناورات وتحركات بالقرب من الجزر
الجزر اليابانيه في الماضي ولكن كل هذه
التحركات كانت عبر سفن وقطع بحريه صينيه
وهمم يعني هذه هي المره الاولى التي تقوم
بها طائره مسيره من دون طيار صينيه وتقترب
من هذه الجزر الجنوبيه في اليابان بالنظر
الى طبيعه هذه الجزر وخاصه جزيره اوكين هو
فهي تضم يعني همم اكبر عدد او القوه
الضاربه كما تسمى
للقوات الامريكيه في اليابان
ويوجد بها نصف العدد الاجمالي من القوات
الامريكيه على الاراضي اليابانيه والمقدر
البالغ عددها 50.000 جندي امريكي وهي ايضا
تحتل 10 او المنشات الامريكيه على هذه
الجزيره تحتل 10% من مساحتها وبالتالي
ربما هناك مراقبون يرون بان هذه الطائره
التي حلقت بالقرب من الجزيره هي ربما
تستهدف او ترسل رساله الى القوات
الامريكيه الموجوده في على هذه الجزيره
خاصه
وكما نعلم ان هناك توتر كبير بين الصين
والولايات المتحده في منطقه بحر شرق الصين
وعبر مضيقي تايوان حيث كثرت همم النشاطات
العسكريه من كلا الجانبين في المنطقه
الطلعات الاستطلاعيه الامريكيه والتي كانت
تقابلها طالعات جويه صينيه حول
على اي حال المنطقه بمجملها بما فيها شبه
الجزيره الكوريه تشهد توتر غير مسبوق حيث
كانت هناك تقابل التهديدات من بعض الاطراف
با ربما عقوبات اقتصاديه او توجيه اللوم
عبر مواقف سياسيه لكن في الفتره الاخيره
نلاحظ ان دول المنطقه غدا سترد على بعضها
البعض بالمثل فاروق عندما
تقوم دوله معينه بتجارب معينه صاروخيه
تقوم الدوله الاخرى بالاعلان عن نيتها
تطوير همم
قواتها الدفاعيه ايضا شكرا لكما